und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
Knatsch Zoff Sandkastenspiele das ist
ungefähr das was der Kanzler am Morgen
in der Pressemappe über seine Regierung
lesen konnte der gute Wille nach der
Sommerpause alles besser zu machen schon
verflogen seit die grüne
Familienministerin gestern im Kabinett
ein Gesetzentwurf ihres fdp-kollegen
blockierte ausgerechnet ein Gesetz zu
Steuererleichterungen für Unternehmen
das im Kern in der Ampel unumstritten
ist und dass der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister schon abgesegnet
hatte worum es bei der
Kindergrundsicherung eigentlich geht und
wer jetzt alles mit wem streitet
berichtet Bernd ihn
Lars Klingbeil hatte sich das schön
vorgestellt politische Sommertour durchs
Land tingeln gute Bilder weg von Ärger
und Streiterei heute Abend steht der
SPD-Chef in Frankfurt erstes Thema
Ärger und Streiterei wenn wir die
Herausforderungen haben eine
rechtsextreme Partei endlich wieder
runterzukriegen dann muss Schluss sein
damit dass diese Regierung sich um sich
selbst dreht wir müssen die Probleme der
Menschen lösen und das ist das was ich
von jedem der einen ministertitel oder
ein Ministerin Titel hat erwarte die
grüne Familie Ministerin Paulus
blockiert gestern ein Herzensprojekt von
FDP Finanzminister Lindner
milliardenschwere Entlastungen für die
Wirtschaft das
wachstumsschancengesetz der Grund
Lindner bremst bei einem Herzensprojekt
von Pause bei der Kindergrundsicherung
ein politisches Revanche faul
ich bedauere das sehr weil man ja auch
sich gemeinsam vorgenommen hatte nach
der Sommerpause anders aufzutreten als
bisher und das hat ja Frau Paus im
Grunde genommen mit ihrer Entscheidung
zunichte gemacht besonders pikant Robert
habecks Wirtschaftsministerium dass die
Grünen Kabinett koordiniert hatte
lindner's Plan schon zugestimmt heute am
Tag nach dem Eklat wollen die Grünen das
Thema herunter Kochen unglücklich sei
die Aktion gewesen ansonsten Flucht in
die Floskel Streit ist misslich das
hätten wir uns anders vorgestellt wir
wollen keinen Streit in der Ampel
sondern konstruktive Arbeit und deswegen
sind jetzt alle auch wir Grünen gefragt
dass wir zu Lösungen kommen die Kinder
Grundsicherung steht im
Koalitionsvertrag wie sie ausgestaltet
werden soll darüber aber streiten FDP
und Grüne seit Monaten die FDP sagt
viele Leistungen für Kinder wurden ja
schon erhöht jetzt müssten die nur noch
leichter an die Leute gebracht werden
das wollen die Grünen auch aber
zusätzlich deutlich mehr Geld für hören
Leistung
bei der Kindergrundsicherung eine
Verwaltungsreform hinzubekommen das ist
aus meiner Sicht völlig ausreichend die
Ministerin selbst war bis zum heutigen
Tag nicht in der Lage zu erklären wofür
sie zusätzliche Milliarden braucht Lisa
Pause wehrt sich heute per
Zeitungsinterview ihr Konzept läge
durchgerechnet vor und die FDP lege
falsch
immer wieder heißt es wir müssten
erstmal erwirtschaften was wir verteilen
können dabei ist es doch umgekehrt wir
brauchen gute Rahmenbedingungen für
Familien auch damit Eltern überhaupt
erwerbstätig sein können laut Studien
ist jedes fünfte Kind in Deutschland von
Armut bedroht über die Folgekosten von
Kinderarmut legt der
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Marcel
Fratscher mit anderen Morgen eine Studie
vor mehr Geld für die Kinder
Grundsicherung sei sinnvoll der Krach
darum aber katastrophal das was die
Bundesregierung macht ist ein
Armutszeugnis dass es Bekämpfung von
Kinderarmut gegen Entlastungen für
Investitionen für Unternehmen
gegeneinander ausspielt das schafft
Unsicherheit das schafft Verunsicherung
und es reduziert auch die soziale
Akzeptanz bei den Menschen für
notwendige Veränderungen Lars klingwald
Sommerreise übrigens geht nur noch bis
zum Wochenende dann muss er zurück nach
Berlin zurück zum Zank
und das wollen wir noch mal vertiefen
mit dem Politikwissenschaftler Albrecht
von Lücke guten Abend nach Berlin guten
Abend
die Sommerpause ist noch nicht ganz rum
da brechen die Grünen einen neuen Streit
vom Zaun haben die nicht kapiert wie
genervt die Leute im Land sind vom
dauerkrach in der Koalition
ja das muss man leider so sehen sage ich
denn es ist fatal was die Grünen sich
ich sage es als Tor angetan haben
regelrecht als Eigentor es ist ein Stück
weit die Revanche man muss es so
begreifen die Enttäuschung vor allem
seitens der Linken Grünen die erlebt
haben dass die FDP in regelmäßig Knüppel
zwischen die Beine geschlagen hat denken
wir an das Gebäude Energiegesetz da war
ist die FDP die massiv gegen die Grünen
geschossen hat da ist der Frust riesig
dass man jetzt aber versucht auf diese
harte Weise die größte FDP auszubremsen
schade letztlich nur der Grünen Partei
selbst das haben wir erlebt jetzt ist
der schwarze Peter gewissermaßen im Feld
der Grünen und die FDP spielt das aus
und überall im thront ein Kanzler der zu
alledem bis vor kurzem nur geschwiegen
hat und jetzt die Versprechung in den
Raum gestellt hat es wird alles besser
aber wir leben nach der Sommerpause ist
vor der Sommerpause es geht genauso
weiter wieder vor zum Kanzler kommen wir
gleich noch mal zurück zu den Grünen was
ist denn ihre Interpretation ist es nur
eine Revanche oder geht es wirklich um
die
neben der Grundsicherung ich kann das
Wort kaum sagen oder versuchen die
Grünen sich jetzt nach dem
heizungsgesetz Desaster als soziale
Partei zu etablieren was ist es das
soziale Anliegen ist ja der Kern dieser
Kindergrundsicherung das war von Anfang
an der versuchter Grünen auf dem Feld
des sozialen auch ein Punkt zu machen
die Kindergrundsicherung war ihr
essential wenn man so sagen will und es
gibt einen Kernproblem sie haben
natürlich die berechtigte Sorge das
angesichts des Wunsches der FDP und vor
allem von Christian Lindner die schwarze
Null zu garantieren vor allem soziale
Themen aber auch ökologische Themen
jetzt vom Tisch fallen es steht alles
unter dem Signum zu allererst die
Wirtschaft das ist die Sorge der Grünen
und die ist nicht unberechtigt dass sie
aber so in die Öffentlichkeit treten und
jetzt gewissermaßen ein Gesetz was ja
auch mit Zustimmung von Robert habe Weg
zustande kommen sollte das
Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz dass sie
es boykitieren ist natürlich fatal weil
sie damit genau das Gegenteil erreichen
dessen was sie wollten Zustimmung für
ihre Projekte die jetzt in Ablehnung
umschlagen und die Grünen ist ja in dem
Zusammenhang auch nicht ganz korrekt
denn Habeck hat ja das Gesetz
durchgewinkt Paus hat nein gesagt gibt
es da jetzt einen flügelstreit in der
Partei ja absolut das ist deutlich
geworden es ist vor allem die linke
Seite die jetzt wesentlich vehementer
vorgehen will da ist die Enttäuschung
besonders groß man hat auch einen
gewissen Zweifel daran dass Robert
Habeck vielleicht manchmal nicht scharf
genug verhandelt bzw sich nicht deutlich
genug artikuliert das war der Wunsch
deswegen gab es ja auch Zustimmung von
Steffi Lemke oder auch von Jürgen
Trittin aber verkannt wurde eben seitens
der Linken in der grünen wie negativ das
zu Lasten der eigenen Seite ausschlägt
deswegen gibt es jetzt den Versuch der
Schadensbegrenzung aber der Schaden ist
angerichtet wir erleben eine
zerstrittene Grüne Partei und eine
zerstrittene Koalition an der alles zu
leiden haben mit dem typischen Ergebnis
die Rechtspopulisten werden sich die
Hände reiben und jetzt noch mal zurück
zum Bundeskanzler angeblich ist er ja
von diesem Streit überrascht worden er
dachte wohl das würde noch vor der
Kabinette Sitzung sich lösen dann hat er
ein Schlichtungsgespräch versucht das
hat auch nicht geklappt und ein macht
dort haben wir auch nicht gehört also
was ist da los ja ein Machtwort kann das
Prinzip ja auch nicht sein wenn man ein
Machtwort und das zum wiederholten Male
denken wir an das Fatale Atomenergie
gesetzt bzw den verteilen Atome Ausstieg
da ist der Kanzler bereits mit einem
Machtwort zu Platz gewesen das kann er
nicht oft wiederholen es geht im Kern um
etwas ganz anderes wir hatten eine lange
Sommerpause in dieser Sommerpause hätte
längst im Hintergrund das Gespräch
stattfinden müssen wie sich drei
Parteien endlich im Vorfeld eines
Gesetzes einigen dass das wieder nicht
gelungen ist der Kanzlerin mit großen
Versprechungen an die Öffentlichkeit
getreten ist wir machen alles besser das
fällt letztlich massiv auf ihn zurück
auch seine Reputation im Schaden
deswegen muss er jetzt entschieden vor
der Klausur in Meseberg die er in
wenigen Wochen stattfinden Ende August
muss er jetzt diese Koalition befrieden
und endlich dafür sorgen dass zukünftig
der Modus wie wenn die das funktionieren
anders stattfindet Gesetze abgesprochen
werden im Vorfeld und das alle Parteien
dazu stehen dann kann es besser werden
sonst wird diese Koalition im Desaster
enden
also schlechtes regierungshandwerk Wagen
sie denn eine Prognose wie lange die
Ampel unter diesen Voraussetzungen noch
durchhält wie lange diese Regierung
zusammenbleibt sie wird und das macht es
fast tragisch sie wird wenn es weiter so
geht gerade weil alle drei Parteien
verlieren aller Voraussicht nach ja bis
zum Ende durchhalten denn der Kitt der
Macht hält die drei Parteien zusammen
aber in der Bevölkerung wird der
Eindruck wecken wachsen lieber ein Ende
mit Schrecken als ein Schrecken ohne
Ende insofern ist das was die Koalition
macht völlig kontraproduktiv und sie
wird wahrscheinlich auf die Weise die
Bevölkerung immer mehr verlieren
Albrecht von Lucke war das
Politikwissenschaftler aus Berlin über
den Kit der Macht vielen Dank dorthin
und noch einen schönen Abend das wünsche
ich Ihnen auch
es gibt noch andere Dinge bei denen man
sich die Augen reibt in diesen Zeiten
Wände Zeiten Deutschland wird ein
Milliarden schweres israelisch
amerikanisches Raketen Abwehrsystem vom
Typ Arrow 3 kaufen und es gibt weder
Demonstrationen in Bonner Hofgarten noch
nennenswerte Kritik aus der Opposition
im Gegenteil aller Orten erleichtertes
Aufatmen seit Putins Krieg gegen die
Ukraine ist die Bedrohung plötzlich
wieder real der Himmel über Deutschland
und Europa werde zum ersten Mal von
einem israelischen System geschützt
freute sich auch Israels Botschafter in
Berlin heute auch das eine Zeitenwende
mattes Feldhoff berichtet
es ist flexibel schnell verfügbar und
vor allem hochpräzise das von Israel und
den USA gemeinsam entwickelte Arrow 3
Abwehrsystem eine Abschussrampe eine
radareinheit und das Kontrollzentrum
sind die einzelnen Komponenten Ende 2025
sollen damit auch mögliche Bedrohungen
durch ballistische Raketen über
Deutschland bekämpft werden können für
rund 4 Milliarden Euro kauft die
Bundeswehr jetzt das System für Experten
in echter gewinnen bis letzten Jahres
hat jeder gesagt ja kostet viel Geld und
ein konventionellen Krieg sowas macht ja
keiner mehr das werden doch die Russen
nicht neu anfangen und da sich natürlich
jetzt die Lage Bewertung
geändert und hier sozusagen schließt
jetzt Deutschland diese fähigkeitslücke
die eigentlich schon sehr lange bekannt
ist aber drei ist einer Probe des System
auch im Schafen Einsatz mit einer
Reichweite von 2400 km insofern kann es
Raketen bereits im Anflug bekämpfen
herausragend dabei die Treffgenauigkeit
das neue System ergänzt die vorhandenen
Abwehrsysteme der Bundeswehr das 40
Jahre alte Patrick System das derzeit
unter anderem in der Ukraine eingesetzt
wird und das neue ihres T-Systems das
war schon bestellt aber noch nicht
geliefert wurde error 3 kommt
vergleichsweise schnell Lieferung schon
im Jahr 2025 es wird in Brandenburg
stationiert werden und dann werden wir
noch ein zweites und ein drittes System
kaufen wobei ein System in
Norddeutschland
eingesetzt wird und ein System in
Süddeutschland und wir können dann mit
diesen drei Systemen das gesamte Gebiet
Deutschlands abdecken weil die USA mit
Entwickler sind bei deren Zustimmung zu
dem deutschen israelischen Geschäft
notwendig für das kleine Land im Nahen
Osten ist der Verkauf von error 3 der
größte Rüstungsexport seiner Geschichte
entsprechend euphorisch klingt der
Verteidigungsminister
dieses System wird mit unserer Hilfe
Deutschland einen Schutzschirm geben wir
sind sehr stolz dass die Deutschen sich
für unser System entschieden haben
dass wir bei Israel ein so modernes
System kaufen es gehört zu den
modernsten der Welt seit den 80er Jahren
entwickelt zeigt auch die Nähe zu Israel
und ist was Besonderes in Israel
verkauft dieses System eben an keinen
außer an Deutschland und ich glaube
angesichts unserer Geschichte ist das
besonders bemerkenswert die Geschichte
der deutschen israelischen
Rüstungsgeschäfte ist eine sehr lange
bisher war sie aber oft sehr einseitig
von Deutschland nach Israel error 3
verändert jetzt diese Geschichte
und wir bleiben beim Thema Ukraine Krieg
und der Diskussion um westliche Waffen
für Kiew damit beginnen die Nachrichten
mit Gundula gossen die Ukraine hat
zugesagt westliche Waffen nicht auf
russischem Gebiet einzusetzen das
garantierte der ukrainische
Außenminister Kollege gegenüber der
Nachrichtenagentur AFP Deutschland
unterstützt die Ukraine unter anderem
mit Leopard 1 Panzern die Bundeswehr
schult derzeit erneut ukrainische
Soldaten in der Bedienung des Leopard 1
A5 die Bundesregierung hatte der Ukraine
178 Kampfpanzer dieses Typs zugesagt
nach dem Militärputsch in Niger arbeitet
die EU an Sanktionen gegen die neuen
Machthaber Außenministerin baerbock will
diese nun vorantreiben bereits verhängte
afrikanische Sanktionen gegen die
Putschisten sind bislang nicht
erfolgreich und belasten nur die
Bevölkerung in Ghana beraten die
militärchefs der westafrikanischen
Staatengemeinschaft ECOWAS über den
möglichen Einsatz einer Eingreiftruppe
in Niger Priorität habe aber eine
diplomatische Lösung
Schweden hat nach mehreren
Koranverbrennungen seine Terrorwarnstufe
auf das zweithöchste Niveau angehoben
Proteste in der muslimischen Welt und
Drohungen islamistischer Extremisten
ließen Anschläge befürchten erklärte der
schwedische Geheimdienst
nach dem Part bei der Parlamentswahl in
Spanien Mitte Juli hat der amtierende
Ministerpräsident Sanchez mit seiner
sozialistischen Partei einen Teil Erfolg
erzielt er konnte seine Kandidatin als
Parlamentspräsidentin durchsetzen sie
wurde auch von den katalanischen
Separatisten gewählt auf deren Stimmen
Sanchez angewiesen ist um auch die
nächste Regierung zu stellen weder das
linke noch das rechte Lager hatten bei
der Parlamentswahl eine Mehrheit erzielt
auch in deutschen Krankenhäusern und
Praxen kommt es zu Tausenden
medizinischen Behandlungsfehlern
Patienten werden verwechselt op-material
im Körper vergessen der medizinische
Dienst der Carsten fordert erneut eine
Meldepflicht für schwerwiegende aber
vermeidbare Fehler die Prüfer sprechen
von einer hohen Dunkelziffer und
bestätigen für das vergangene Jahr
321 Behandlungsfehler bei rund einem
Drittel mit Schäden von Dauer bei 84
Patienten führten diese Fehler zum Tod
die Szene ist bis heute unvorstellbar am
17 August 1962 rennt ein junger Mann von
Ost nach West am Stacheldraht Zaun vor
der Berliner Mauer wird er von
DDR-Grenzern angeschossen er stirbt
langsam und allein weil die DDR
Grenzschützer ihm nicht helfen und die
US-Soldaten auf der anderen Seite den
Befehl haben still zu halten der
18-Jährige hieß Peter Fechter und sein
öffentliches sterben erschütterte die
Berliner vor 61 Jahren auf beiden Seiten
wie kein mauertoter davor und danach
Opferverbände fordern seit langem dass
eine Straße in Berlin nach ihm benannt
werden solle aber es kommt nicht dazu
Christa versucht zu ergründen warum
Berlin-Mitte die Zimmerstraße führt
vorbei am Checkpoint Charlie dem
weltberühmten Hotspot des Kalten Krieges
eine schlichte Stele erinnert ein paar
hundert Meter weiter an Peter Fechter
mauerflüchtling 18 Jahre alt genau hier
qualvoll nach einer Stunde verblutet
Bilder die um die Welt ging seit mehr
als einem Jahrzehnt fordern
aufarbeitungsverbände eine
peter-fechter-straße warum
an einer Stelle geht man vorbei wie an
einer Litfaßsäule wer nicht unmittelbar
damit was zu tun hatte oder Erinnerungen
hat der kann damit eigentlich gar nichts
anfangen ist aber eine Straße da dann
spricht man überall von einer
peter-fechter-straße das heißt die Frage
steht dann im Hintergrund wer war denn
das
spontan versucht der Maurerlehrling
Fechter am Nachmittag des 17 August 62
mit einem Freund die Sperranlagen zu
überwinden seinem Kollegen gelingt die
Flucht obwohl mindestens 25 Schüsse
fallen Fechter bleibt schwer verletzt
liegen eine Stunde flieht er verzweifelt
doch niemand hilft
für die Grenze gibt es später Prämien im
Westen hingegen wütende Proteste
der Skandal liegt eigentlich darin und
das wissen wir erst heute dass das
Eingreifen der Amerikaner von Washington
selbst untersagt wurde sieben deutsche
Kommunen haben mittlerweile eine Peter
fechter-straße nur nicht in Berlin seit
Jahrzehnten hat es zuständige
bezirksamtmitte alle Anfragen
abgewiegelt unsere Bitte um ein
Interview wird urlaubsbedingt abgesagt
schriftlich heißt es die Stele sei sehr
sinnvoll und angemessen eine Umbenennung
sei nicht umsetzbar
wie jedes Jahr wird im August in der
Hauptstadt an die Mauer Opfer erinnert
doch gibt es in Sachen Peter Fechter
Straße beim neuen schwarz-roten Senat
ein Umdenken
ich persönlich würde mich freuen wenn
Berlin eine solche Straße bekommt die
Diskussion führen wir seit vielen Jahren
meine Partei hat sich auch immer dafür
ausgesprochen zuständig ist der
angelegene Bezirk insofern muss man
insbesondere dort werben für mich ist
entscheidend möchte die Familie das wenn
die Familie das wünscht dann wäre ich
sehr dafür dass man diesen Schritt auch
geht so wird die Verantwortung seit
Jahren in Berlin hin und her geschoben
zwischen Lippenbekenntnissen des Senats
und einem Grünen regierten Bezirk Mitte
der die Umbenennung nicht will das
erinnert mich an die Frage wenn ich
gegen die Mauer demonstriert habe
glauben Sie denn daran dass die Mauer
jemals fallen wird und ich habe gesagt
ja sie wird fallen und ich werde das
Erleben und ich bin jetzt im 18
Lebensjahr aber ich denke mal ich erlebe
das noch es wäre wohl ein kleines Wunder
wenn die peterfechterstraße tatsächlich
kommen würde
und wir machen weiter mit Nachrichten
zunächst aus der Wirtschaft und nochmal
mit Gundula an den Finanzmärkten wurde
an diesem Donnerstag ein Protokoll der
jüngsten Sitzung der US-Notenbank
studiert gerade veröffentlicht mit einem
klaren Hinweis auf Unsicherheit der Fett
in Bezug auf eine weitere Zinserhöhung
Sina meinitz an der Börse
Unsicherheit mögen die Märkte gar nicht
so ist es also Anleger die nach diesem
Protokollen der US-Notenbank fällt auf
Klarheit für die Kapitalmärkte gehofft
haben die wurden enttäuscht denn die
Fett hält sich die Tür für weitere
Zinserhöhungen offen und diese
Unwägbarkeiten am Markt haben den Dax
auch im Tagesverlauf auf Talfahrt
geschickt am Ende verabschiedet sich das
Börsenbarometer im Minus bei einem Stand
von
15.67 Punkten eine Zinspause oder eine
weitere Zinsanhebung wird in den USA
heftig diskutiert es bestimmten nach wie
vor erhebliche Aufwärtsrisiken für die
Inflation
dämpfen allerdings die Wirtschaft und
könnten die Arbeitslosigkeit in die Höhe
treiben ein Spagat für die Fett der noch
nicht bewältigt ist die Notenbanken
Tagen ja erst wieder im September was
bedeutet das Warten auf die mögliche
nächste Zinsentscheidung für die Anleger
ja diese haben acht Stellung für die
Anleger schließt konkrete Investitionen
häufig aus ganz einfach weil sie derzeit
zu risikoreich wären die zinsfrage
stellt sich auf die Europäische
Zentralbank ihr oberstes Ziel sind ja
stabile Preise in der Eurozone und noch
ist laut ezb-chefin Lagat offen ob es im
September zu einer Zinspause oder einer
Erhöhung kommen wird auch hier wird auf
die Wirtschaft geblickt Kredite
verteuern sich im Falle eines
Zinsanstiegs nämlich erneut deshalb
kommt es auf maßvolles Handeln an
steigende Zinsen aber auch haben aber
auch noch einen anderen Effekt sie
erhöhen die Attraktivität von Tages und
Festgeldkonten vielen Dank an Sina meine
Netze
heftige Gewitter haben nun tagelang
Überschwemmungen und Schäden verursacht
in Baden-Württemberg sind mittlerweile
zwei Menschen nach Blitzschlägen
gestorben der Deutsche Wetterdienst
warnt aktuell noch vor einzelnen
schweren Gewittern in Teilen von Bayern
und vor einer Hitzewelle ab morgen im
gesamten Südosten Deutschlands
von Starkregen besonders getroffen wurde
das Rhein-Main-Gebiet rund um Frankfurt
der Betrieb des Flughafens musste
zeitweise eingestellt werden
im Nordosten der spanischen Kanareninsel
Teneriffa kämpfen hunderte
Feuerwehrleute gegen einen schweren
Waldbrand der sich bislang nicht
eindämmen lässt betroffen ist eine
Fläche von mehr als 2600 Hektar
ausgebrochen war der Waldbrand nach
extremer Hitze und Trockenheit am
Dienstag zwischen den Gemeinden Arafo
und Candelaria mehrere Dörfer in der bei
Urlaubern beliebten Regionen wurden
evakuiert der regionalpräsident spricht
vom kompliziertesten Feuer auf den
Kanarischen Inseln seit 40 Jahren
seit ihrer Entstehung hat sich die Erde
stark verändert Berge Meere und
Kontinente sind entstanden und vergangen
Tier und Pflanzenarten haben sich
ausgebreitet und sind wieder
ausgestorben so wie vor 500 Millionen
Jahren da entwickelten sich unter Wasser
die ersten echten Tierarten Würmer und
Quallen bevölkerten die Meere und auch
der gefährlichste Räuber des Kambriums
der ein Meter lange anomalokaris woher
wissen wir das weil jedes Zeitalter
steinerne Abdrücke hinterlassen hat
durch Funde von Dinosaurierknochen in
Erd- und Gesteinsschichten wissen wir
heute viel über die Erdzeitalter Trias
Jura und Kreide vor über 65 Millionen
Jahren
seit über zwei Millionen Jahren befinden
wir uns nun im Quartär genauer im nach
Eiszeitalter doch zum ersten Mal
verändert nun der Mensch den Verlauf der
Erdgeschichte so massiv das
Wissenschaftler aus aller Welt eine neue
Epoche vorschlagen das anthropo Prozent
Beweise dafür finden sich an
abgelegensten Orten wie dem Crawford
lake in Kanada immer die Spuren des
Zeitalters des Menschen
fordert am Rand eines kleinen Sees in
Kanada etwas ganz Großes ein neues
Kapitel der Erdgeschichte das
Anthropozän in dem Menschen die
Erdentwicklung dramatisch verändern seit
gerade mal 73 Jahren
das ist natürlich geologisch nur ein
kurzer Augenblick aber trotzdem
vergleichbar mit dem Asteroideneinschlag
vor 66 Millionen Jahren
hier im unscheinbaren Crawford Lake
finden sich die Belege die den Vergleich
mit der Katastrophe rechtfertigen die
einst alles verändert hatte
bei den jährlichen Bohrungen füllen die
Wissenschaftler Stahlröhren mit
Trockeneis und Ethanol versenken sie im
See die Sedimente die dann an der Röhre
festfrieren belegen wie menschliches
Handeln seit Mitte des letzten
Jahrhunderts die Natur massiv beschädigt
deshalb wollen Forscher aus aller Welt
nun die Epoche des anthropos 10 aushofen
wir bemerken ja alle die Veränderungen
in der Umwelt warum sollte das nicht in
der Erdgeschichte so vermerkt werden
an der kalten Universität Otter war
werden die Proben sorgfältig
fotografiert chemische und biologische
Stoffe analysiert die Ergebnisse wurden
durch andere Messpunkte rund um den
Erdball bestätigt Professor Petersen
zeigt uns wie ab den 50er Jahren des
letzten Jahrhunderts durch sauren Regen
jährliche calcid Ablagerungen
verschwanden industrielle
Luftverschmutzung massiver Dünger
Einsatz Atombombentest alles hinterließ
Spuren
und der Zustand der Erde das schließen
wir aus diesen Anhaltspunkten und vielen
anderen die mit der enormen
bevölkerungsmenge heute zu tun haben
dieser Zustand wird nie wieder so sein
wie er vorher war
auch deshalb nimmt die Häufigkeit von
Katastrophen weiter zu die Temperaturen
steigen es ist etwas durcheinander
geraten anhaltende Extremwetter lagen
auch weil sich der Golfstrom verlangsamt
der Jetstream wird aussieht wie ein
Gemälde von Van Gogh
[Musik]
die Art der extreme ihre Häufigkeit auch
ihr Auftauchen in der Zukunft diese
Dinge sind eng verbunden mit dem
Klimawandel und dem menschlichen Handeln
über die letzten 100 150 Jahren
die Geschwindigkeit ist
besorgniserregend denn sie erhöht die
Wahrscheinlichkeit von sozialen Unruhen
im Wettbewerb um knapper werdende
Ressourcen und um die wenigen noch
angenehmen Orte auf dieser Erde
die Ergebnisse aus dem kleinen sehen
Kanada belegen eine Entwicklung die sich
kaum zurückdrehen lässt vielleicht so
oft von ziehen können wir sie wenigstens
Abbremsen damit die Menschheit überlebt
und das war es von uns für heute wir
empfehlen Ihnen noch nach uns die Doku
macht Poker an der Ostsee unsere
Korrespondenten sind an den Küsten der
Ostsee entlang gereist und haben dort
Geschichten erzählt wie sich das Leben
durch den Krieg in der Ukraine verändert
hat unbedingt angucken ja und uns gibt
es morgen wieder wie immer freitags um
22 Uhr schönen Abend noch und tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in den nächsten
Tagen steht hauptsächlich die Hitze im
Vordergrund dabei kommt die Hitze aus
dem Süden und erreicht uns da sind
Temperaturen über 30 Grad häufiger drin
bis 35 sogar und dann kommt zum Samstag
mit diesem T4 Richtung Atlantic da ist
eine Kaltfront drin die erreicht uns
dann gibt's im Nordwesten Schauer und
Gewitter aber erstmal die kommende Nacht
unterlassen die Schauer und Gewitter
allmählich nach nach Westen hin ist es
schon aufgelocker teilweise bildet sich
dich daneben die Temperaturen sinken bis
auf 14 Grad im Alpenrand und 19 Grad im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet häufig ist es mit in
dieser Nacht morgen einen Tagesverlauf
viel Sonnenschein und einzelne schauen
und Gewitter z.B über der Mitte
hauptsächlich über den Bergland und das
bei höchsten Temperaturen von bis zu 21
Grad in Schleswig-Holstein deutlich kühl
hier an den Küsten aber je weiter man
nach Süden schaut und auch nach Osten
hier bis 35 Grad im Südwesten
Deutschlands und hier noch einmal 31
sogar ganz im Osten Deutschlands der
Blick auf die nächsten Tage am Samstag
bis 35 Grad heiß von Nordwesten Schauer
und Gewitter Sonntag und montags sind
dann deutlich Trockner Gewitter sind da
nur vereinzelt dabei ein schöner Abend